[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
jury selection is underway as four
michigan men stand trial for attempted
kidnap of their state's governor plus my
reading of the case file and my
understanding of the evidence in the
case is that she was murdered
by ryan duke while in her home here in
irwin county the murder of one-time
georgia beauty queen tara grinstead a
pre-trial hearing puts prosecutors on
the witness stand and a california woman
now charge for faking her own kidnapping
back in 2016. but first we finally got
to hear from scotty david about the
discrepancy on his juror questionnaire
we break down the testimony of federal
juror number 50 who helped convict
gillane maxwell law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin a federal juror who helped
convict sex trafficker elaine maxwell is
questioned under oath after answers on
his juror questionnaire didn't match his
real life experiences he testified on
tuesday quote this is one of the biggest
mistakes i have made in my life
on the stand david acknowledged he had
been sexually assaulted by his
stepbrother as a child but indicated on
his juror questionnaire that he had
never been sexually abused on tuesday
david told federal judge allison nathan
that he quote flew through the
questionnaire and was super distracted
while filling it out in a noisy room
dave was part of a federal jury that
convicted maxwell on counts of sex
trafficking and procuring minors for
jeffrey epstein's abuse after the
verdict david spoke out to several news
outlets commenting on his own experience
with sexual assault since then doubt has
been cast over maxwell's guilty verdict
ahead of tuesday's questioning david
indicated he would invoke his fifth
amendment right if called to the stand
prosecutors then offered david immunity
for his testimony which the department
of justice signed off on on monday that
means david cannot be prosecuted for any
information revealed during his
testimony both sides are due back in
court on march 15 to discuss the
ramifications of david's testimony
law on crime's adam classfeld was at the
federal courthouse tuesday as david
questioned under oath he explains how
news broke of the juror questionnaire
discrepancy and why maxwell's defense
feels they may be granted a retrial
it came out the more
he told news organizations about the
inside of deliberations he said this
verdict is for all sexual assault
victims he talked about how
his experiences with
sexual abuse informed not only his
deliberations but helped other jurors in
their deliberations because remember you
know we spoke throughout the trial that
the
key part of the prosecution's case was
grooming
and that a lot of the ways that elaine
maxwell's lawyers tried to undermine
testimony from the victims was pointing
out discrepancies
in traumatic memory scotty david said in
the media interviews again and again
that he understood that
memory traumatic memory in particular
isn't perfect
in the wake of sexual abuse and that he
said that perspective informed his
deliberations
this is why
that's why gallane maxwell's lawyers are
saying hey this thing that he did not
disclose an injury questionnaire
informed this verdict and that's why
they're pinning their hopes on a retrial
on those interviews
joining us today is civil rights
attorney sue ann robinson and terry
austin suanne according to adam we will
not see any of the other maxwell jurors
testify why may that be
i think that the inquiry is focused on
him and what he said and and whether or
not what he was saying or his
experiences affected um the outcome of
the case so i don't think there's really
a need to call the other jurors i think
the issue has to do with his
misrepresentation and what he possibly
said when he was in the juror jury room
but i don't think there's there's a need
for the other jurors to become involved
yeah it seems like as you said the issue
is squarely on him and they may have got
all the information they needed but
terry david said his answer was an
innocent mistake should the judge just
accept that as his explanation
you know this is somewhat a subjective
process the judge has to seriously
consider what he testified to he
basically said he made an innocent
mistake he said that he thought that the
sexual abuse applied to friends and
family and didn't apply to him she's
going to have to determine whether or
not that was the case but more
importantly brian she's going to have to
determine whether or not it affected his
deliberation and the entire jury and we
know based on what adam was reporting
and what we've heard that it did affect
the deliberation particularly of david's
test you know
he basically said it affected him and we
know it also affected the rest of that
jury and as much as we may not want to
see a new trial
you know maxwell is entitled to under
the constitution of fair and impartial
jury so i definitely think that there's
a good possibility she could get a new
trial yeah and that's the one part where
i'm thinking maybe one other juror
should testify to say hey he said this i
heard it and it kind of affected my
decision maybe maybe not but we'll see
how it plays out and of course giving
the update as it comes in
also in federal court in new york jury
selection began tuesday in the trial for
accused sarah lawrence sex cult leader
lawrence wray for about 10 years ray
allegedly abused and extorted several of
his daughter's classmates who were
students at sarah lawrence college it
all started when the 62 year old former
wall street trader
moved into his daughter's on-campus
housing in 2010 just days after being
released from prison officials say he
soon gained control over his daughter's
friends presenting himself as a father
figure and holding group therapy
sessions over the next 10 years he
allegedly extorted money from the
students and isolated them from their
families even moving them into an
apartment in new york city then
eventually to north carolina he's
alleged crimes were investigated after
authorities caught wind of a 2019 new
york magazine article revealing the
abuse and manipulation one of the
students was indicted for her role in
the scheme she will face a separate
trial set for this summer ray faces a 17
count indictment including charges of
racketeering sex trafficking forced
labor money laundering and tax evasion
he faces life in prison if convicted
opening statements are expected to begin
on wednesday
we're now hearing for the first time
from curtis reeves just weeks after he
was acquitted in the murder of chad
olson law on crime daily brought you
capital gavel coverage of the trial that
ended with a not guilty verdict for
reeves prosecutors say reeves shot and
killed olson in 2014 after a conflict
broke out at a movie theater reeves an
ex-police officer claimed self-defense
saying he shot and killed olson
believing he would be attacked he says
also was on his cell phone during the
movie's previews and threw popcorn at
him after reece asked him to turn off
his phone reed spent nearly eight years
on house arrest awaiting trial after a
failed stand your ground hearing in 2017
reeves went to trial in january on
second-degree murder charges a jury
acquitted reeves of all charges after
only three hours of deliberation in an
exclusive interview with abc news reeves
explained why he reacted by grabbing his
weapon
i was looking at the previews and then
suddenly out of the corner of my eye
he's on his feet
and
i got hit in the face you got hit in the
face right there was something that
flashed in front of my face and at the
same time
my vision kind of went blurry and is
that the point where you pulled your gun
well for for 48 years i've carried a
firearm either on duty as law
enforcement or as retired with all the
proper credentials
it was uh
at some point uh when i realized that he
was trying to either reach for me or hit
me again or strike me again is at that
point is when i went for the weapon do
you wish you left your gun at home had i
left that my gun at home there's a good
chance that i wouldn't be here today
in a statement to abc news olson's widow
said in part quote for eight long years
i had to wait and try to fight for
justice even though even though the jury
got it wrong i will not accept this
result lying down
still ahead on law and crime daily
accused killer ryan duke once again in
the courtroom ahead of his trial in the
high profile case of a missing beauty
queen but first a california woman who
officials say faked her own kidnapping
now faces even more serious charges at
the federal level we break down the case
of jerry papini next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
california mother who claims she had
been kidnapped is now facing federal
charges accused of lying to the fbi mail
fraud and more law and crimes angela
levy is here with the details on sherry
papini's case
brian when sherry papini went missing in
november of 2016 it set off a massive
search effort not only in california
where she lived but also in several
other states she was found 22 days later
on an interstate about 150 miles from
the location where she actually lived
federal officials say that in august of
2020 papini lied when confronted by fbi
agents with evidence that she faked her
own abduction but that she continued
with her original story that she had
been kidnapped papini claimed two
hispanic women in a dark suv abducted
and tortured her but her ex-boyfriend
told investigators papini actually
stayed with him during the time she was
missing and that she inflicted injuries
including branding on herself papini was
married with two children at the time
surveillance video emerged showing
papini near a church and you can
actually see her on the left of the
screen she claimed at that time that she
was running away from her abductors now
papini is also accused of mail fraud as
part of this she's also accused of
defrauding the california victim's
compensation board of more than thirty
thousand dollars for therapy visits and
about a thousand dollars of that was
used to buy blinds for her home
the sheriff of shasta county is not
ruling out that others could be charged
in this case he says that sherry papini
and her family used her disappearance
for financial gain raising about nine
thousand dollars on gofundme and using
that money for personal expenses and to
pay off credit card bills
brian
thanks and jeanette let's bring back
civil rights attorney suanne robinson
and terry oz as we jump into the case of
sherry papini terry why is this a
federal case and not a state case
well there are multiple reasons it's a
federal case that's under federal
jurisdiction first of all they called
the fbi to help investigate to use their
resources and she lied to the fbi and
once you lied to the fbi that is a
federal offense and she was even warned
during her interview not to lie it's
also federal because of that mail fraud
that angenette mentioned automatically
that becomes federal and that gofundme
campaign is what makes it that mail
fraud so she has for a number of reasons
also she went after state lines so that
too is another reason why it can come
under the federal jurisdiction so it's a
shame it's a waste of resources but i'm
glad they
finally are going after her all right so
maybe i'm connecting docs that shouldn't
be connected but a lot of stuff i'm
hearing is familiar we saw the chicago
police department seek restitution in
the jesse smollette case for his hoax of
a crime could we see the same here
we need to
we need to see all of that force and
vigor in this prosecution because this
is even worse because she's involved
people potentially internationally
through the gofundme account and made
direct misrepresentations to the fbi so
i definitely hope that we're going to
see her having to pay restitution for
all the resources that she used and and
really have to go through with the whole
thing the trial everything there she
should not be treated any differently
than jessie smallett or any other person
who improperly uses police to effectuate
a scam all right we'll see how that
plays out and chad how did the fbi and
sheriff's detectives find the
ex-boyfriend you mentioned
yeah it's really interesting brian he
didn't just come out of the woodwork
what happened was when sherry papini was
found a truck driver called 9-1-1 the
police come and pick her up she's taken
to the hospital they get her clothing
they test it for dna they find dna
in her underwear they run that through a
familial dna site
they find out who this person could be
related to they kind of deduced it from
there and they got a bottle out of his
trash swabbed it got a dna sample it was
a match and then they went and
interviewed him and he came clean all
right interesting process there we'll
see how this case unfolds and make sure
to give you more updates as it does
thank you all coming up on law and crime
daily the federal trial begins as four
michigan men stand trial for attempted
kidnapping of their state's governor
plus nearly 20 years after tara
grinstein's murder an accused murderer
will soon stand trial the latest
development in the case of ryan duke
[Music]
welcome back a high profile case is back
in the courtroom this week ahead of the
trial for accused killer ryan duke a man
charged with the murder of former
georgia teacher and beauty queen tara
grinstead duke will stand trial for
murder 16 years after grinstead went
missing prosecutors say he and his
accomplice beau dukes were former
students at the school where grinstead
worked the news of grenstead's
disappearance in 2005 swept the nation
but the investigation soon turned cold
the former beauty queen was declared
dead in 2010. then in 2017 investigators
said a tip had led them to arrest duke
and dukes dukes had already been
convicted and sentenced in connection to
the crime for helping cover up
grinstead's death he was expected to
testify at tuesday's pre-trial hearing
about a meeting he had had with
investigators in 2017 but attorneys
agreed he could speak to his lawyers
before taking the stand the special
assistant district attorney did testify
about that meeting he answered questions
from the prosecution about any
discussions about deals for dukes
do you know having been the prosecutor
one of the prosecutors on both the irwin
county case the ben hill case and the
wilcox case of any deals that have ever
been made with bodice there have never
been any deals that i have made or that
i'm aware that you or mr baldwin has
made to mr bo dukes ever and in fact
there's never even been use immunity
given to mr dukes at this point there
has never
mr
beau dukes has never testified for me
and that's all i can speak of is what i
have done in ben hill nor in wilcox he
has never testified
in any grand jury proceeding i never
gave him immunity and he never testified
in any proceeding that i've been a part
of ever
civil rights attorney suanne robinson
and co-host terry austin are back to
break down the death of a georgia beauty
queen terry what have we learned about
the trial in today's hearing so far
well the whole issue today was whether
or not beau dukes was granted this
immunity whether there was some sort of
plea deal and in fact he didn't get on
the stand but the prosecution and the
defense in that case did testify and
they made it extremely clear that there
was never any sort of deal made so it
looks like ryan duke is going to have to
basically go to trial and beau dukes is
not going to be an issue at all as far
as that case is concerned interesting
now suanne the state supreme court now
says duke will have state funds for
experts based on the experts that he's
asking for what kind of defense could we
expect
i think that based on the what he's
asking for he's hoping to
give some sort of testimony about
or introduce evidence that it's it
wasn't it kind of like it wasn't me um
experts hopefully
i mean there's a lot of issues in this
case in terms of identity and i think
he's gonna try to attack the dna
evidence
all right we'll see how it plays out of
course we've got dna experts probably a
false confession expert it's going to be
interesting to see how they try to raise
reasonable doubt to the experts but of
course as it starts we are here at law
and crime daily we give you that gavel
to gavel coverage when we come back jury
selection begins in federal court as
four men are charged with attempted
kidnapping of the michigan governor our
terry austin breaks down the case so far
welcome back to law and crime daily
federal jury selection begins in
michigan as four men are charged with
conspiracy to kidnap governor gretchen
whitmer in october 2020. our own terri
austin has more on the case
ryan prosecutors claim the four men
conspired to kidnap governor whitmore
because of her actions to contain covet
19 during the beginning of the pandemic
prosecutors plan to use secret
recordings and key witnesses to build
their case the four men barry croft jr
daniel harris adam fox and brandon
caserta are accused of taking
substantial steps over several months
including secret messaging gun drills in
the woods and a drive to whitmer's
second home to determine how to blow up
a nearby bridge the fbi infiltrated the
group and thwarted the plan they
originally arrested six men but two of
them ty garvin and caleb franks have
pleaded guilty and will appear as key
witnesses for the prosecution the trial
could last more than a month and judge
robert jonker told prospective jurors
quote this isn't your average criminal
case because of the extraordinary
allegations of a plot against an elected
official
if convicted all four men could face the
prospect of spending the rest of their
lives in prison brian
you heard it there two of the defendants
have already pled guilty do you expect
them to be the prosecutor's star witness
and kind of tie everything together here
absolutely
they participated in the crime and the
accusations and so they're absolutely
going to be the star witnesses
right now terry they never actually
kidnapped the governor they it appears
they only took steps so what does the
prosecution need to prove in order to
make their case well basically brian
this is a conspiracy to kidnap so under
title 18 of the u.s code they actually
don't have to show that the crime was
actually committed all they have to do
is focus on that plan and the steps that
were taken to execute that plan and as
we know the plan involved more than one
defendant here we have multiple
defendants so it has to have more than
one person to have a conspiracy and
frankly the prosecution has indicated
that they have much evidence against
these witnesses and these defendants
because they have all of the evidence
that they need they have recordings they
have people who are going to testify so
i think they have a solid case i think
they're going to be able to show the
conspiracy now swan real quick want to
come back to you any potential defense
you see here i mean there's a lot of
evidence against him it seems
well i've been i saw in one of the
january 6th uh defendants say that they
were bragging that was their defense
that they just talked a lot but i think
the issue here is that the state has
evidence that they took steps in
furtherance of the cons of the
conspiracy and that's really what's
going to kind of lock them in and and
give the prosecution hopefully a
successful case yeah it's kind of an
interesting argument they were just
bragging and i can see that being a
potential defense here especially
looking at what happened january 6 uh
potential defendants and in this case
well we'll see how it plays out and
we'll continue to keep eyes on this case
even though it's a federal case can't
put a camera in it well thank you both
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you